[Music]
no she's not avenging Jo's in their
chops of peppers there's got about 12
things going on the stone I mean the
guy's a freak you can see him currently
organizing his own criminal jumping the
coughing and saying goodbye to her and
saying the prayer at the end close the
lid Yesi of wah buh-bah thank you don't
bother the kitchen for nothing excellent
coming up to halfway there and he won't
offload why is he paying all those
members of staff and he's doing
everything on his shoulders
Chris not letting his brigade near the
stove means some customers are still
waiting for the mains this guy won't
accept help from anyone I've got to get
through to him somehow then you start
talking to your brigades boy
okay guys hello how are you hi Ali let's
get on with it I've got the fish you've
got everything
Bres last table look at me for two
seconds is there any chance that you can
stand over here right I'll let your
sous-chef right your second chef in your
third chef cook the last table go
outside and take some fresh air just out
there just just a few minutes you come
over here and you gonna get some fresh
air out out right let them do it okay
just the last table I'll kill you guys
if you don't do it properly you're gonna
be dead in two weeks if you continue
like this let it go
last time how long listen for three
minutes
come on guys
give one more leave them alone ha it's
fine that's something I have to work on
but you know when your love cooking
that's what you do very tough very
savoury mince really come string put a
flavor a little bit spice really nice
the booze wonderful the place you've got
so much charm so much character such a
great world service is over and my
diners are leaving happy
okay right first of all service unique
ladies well done thank you
yeah even down to the handwritten
tickets okay the first thing you went in
second ticket two tables of four doesn't
matter and that's for the kitchen food
is delicious sublime just amazing my
biggest problem is you I want thousands
more customers to enjoy your food but
you won't be around if you don't open up
and delegate oh well you'll be surprised
to what it does messy well done
seriously well done really good what was
good for me is realizing that I must
delegate you take it on board put it
this way I always take more break mm-hmm
[Music]
guys a genius he cooks like an angel
he hasn't got all the fixtures and
fittings and the posh address but what
he has got is an amazing palette and for
me somebody to watch very closely